[Musique]
le rendez-vous junior de la semaine
c'est de la danse contemporaine pour les
plus jeunes avec une histoire bien
connue de tous le petit chaperon rouge
bonjour mélanine bonjour caves et les
aventures de ce petit chaperon rouge
sont à découvrir jusqu'au 7 janvier au
théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines
un spectacle d'une quarantaine de
minutes et s'est créé par la compagnie
québécoise cas public alors hélène
blackburn a choisi ce conte par un
attachement par souvenir le petit
chaperon rouge étant le premier petit
livre qu'on lui a offert écoutez le
buste décide de secret quand même un
climat qui était pas ce que j'appelle
mon film d'horreur pour enfin vous
décrire à fait à cette tension pour
jouer avec les tensions et relâchement
de récit c'est une histoire qui était
une matière en fait c'est plus une
matière que l'histoire me sentais moins
de besoin de le raconter que je ça me
permettait de l'évoqué pas de ses fruits
quand même nom ça faisait compris vous
l'avez vu en plus dans les interviews
hélène le dit avec le sourire la troupe
existe depuis maintenant 25 ans et ça
fait même quinze ans qu'elle fait des
spectacles que pour enfants ou à voir en
famille tout est adapté à l'âge des
spectateurs ça s'adresse même dès l'âge
de deux ans on joue sur les peurs du
petit pas chaperon rouge les ya de la
poésie la musique et le mouvement
rassure elle et ellen elle même nous a
rassurés y'a pas de pleurs à la fin et
les danseurs utilise le langage des
signes
car l'un des danseurs et source et ça et
les sort on le voit à l'image en l'une
des reines
il est équipé pourtant un pour entendre
mais ça a inspiré la compagnie ça fait
très longtemps qu'ils travaillent
ensemble et ça rentre c'est très
graphique on le voit moi j'ai vu les
répétitions c'est très intéressant et
c'est par contre la ligne d est la
langue des signes québécoise
donc les français ne comprennent pas
nécessairement un petit chaperon rouge
canadien avec trois loups également ça
c'est une petite nouveauté dans ce
spectacle et ce n'est pas pour eux c'est
pas parce que c'est pour les enfants que
tout aussi simple pour autant
non c'est pas tout à fait ça mais ce
sont quand même des petites saynètes ça
joue sur la lumière la musicalité pas
nécessairement d'histoire mme ce sont
des évocations mai
il y a beaucoup de technique il y a
beaucoup de virtuosité d'enlèvement et
s'est aussi associée une multitude de
petites et des mots sur scène écoutez ce
qu'on dit hélène blackburn
je passais mon immense coffre à joindre
mon coffre à jouet idéal donc on a on a
un trait qui vient donner à la fois le
temps et l'espace dur ici on réfère à
beaucoup d'objets qui sont issus du
quotidien des enfants donc ça crée une
espèce d'effet de reconnaissance par
même temps ça nous permet de dégager une
certaine poésie parce qu'on les place
sur scène et on les utilise de manière
différente et pour découvrir ce que fera
jouer direction le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines dernière
représentation ce cm 17 janvier à 18
heures